[Música]
hoy se conoce al veredicto en el juicio
por los atentados del 13 de noviembre
del año 2015 en parís y sant dennis tras
149 días de audiencia la fiscalía ha
solicitado penas que van de los 5 años
de prisión hasta la cadena perpetua
contra los 19 acusados seis de los
cuales son juzgados pese a estar en
paradero desconocido o presuntamente han
muerto en siria nosotros entonces
queremos saludar a nuestra segunda
invitada clemens wheat ella es abogada
al colegio de parís que está
representando a víctimas civiles
extranjeras en el juicio del teatro
bataclán gracias abogada que manso por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 para darnos digamos un
contexto le pregunto primero cómo es
según su opinión se ha desarrollado este
juicio histórico y multi digamos con
muchas personas incluidas en francia
bueno fue un juicio extraordinario por
muchos aspectos primero por la duración
o sea más de 10 meses de audiencia y 149
días de audiencia más de 3000 partes
civiles que han sido representadas
durante durante los debates y 400 de
ellas escuchada en una sala de la corte
de parís construida especialmente para
este juicio por todos estos aspectos fue
un juicio extraordinario y yo creo que
el mayor desafío de los jueces que van a
dar su decisión en unas horas es
justamente de dar una decisión ilegal la
misma edición que hubiesen dado en
cualquier juicio ordinario respetando
nuestros estándar de ley de derecho y
después de un juicio que ha sido estable
también que más usted está representando
a víctimas civiles desde el teatro de
bataclán en la ciudad de parís es el
escenario donde lamentablemente fueron
asesinadas la mayor cantidad de personas
esa fatídica noche que dicen las
víctimas a que usted representa a un
mejor dicho también los familiares de
estas víctimas
si representamos a 12 víctimas la
mayoría de ellas se ando hispanófonos
una familia chilena en una familia
española en particular bueno yo creo que
lo que más les importaban a estas
familias eran poder llegar a una forma
de manifestación de la verdad y entender
mejor la cronología de los hechos
acercarse un poco también de los últimos
minutos que han podido ser los de los
que han fallecidos del que era sus
hermanos hijos o marido algo muy
importante también fundamental para
estas víctimas extranjeras que no
manejan el francés o poco y que no
conocen a nuestro país era justamente de
poder participar a los debates y siendo
abogada el papel de nuestro equipo fue
mayoría mente de asegurarnos de eso y de
facilitar a nuestros clientes bueno que
haya una traducción de los días en la
corte pelear con el ministro de justicia
francés para que la web de radio que era
una captación del audio de los debates
esta accesibilidad fuera cosas así que
pueden parecer básicas pero que para
víctimas son fundamental por qué para
ellos la participación efectiva al
juicio es una forma de reparación claro
hablando de esa reparación y la justicia
que se espera que se concluya después de
este mega juicio histórico le quiero
preguntar si cree que estas penas que
pone la fiscalía que van entre cinco
años de prisión hasta la cadena perpetua
y como por ejemplo lo piden para sala
abdeslam son suficientes porque también
hemos visto testimonios de varias de las
víctimas o familiares de las víctimas
que lamentablemente fueron asesinadas en
este caso la sala concierto de bataclán
que dice que no son suficientes que
ellos esperaban muchísimo más al castigo
por parte de las autoridades francesas
en este caso también de la fiscalía que
es la que pone la pena
bueno la fiscalía ha propuesto penas que
son de las más altas que existen en
nuestro sistema legal francia sigue
siendo un estado de derecho con una
jerarquía de pena y encontramos de que
la fiscalía ha propuesto penas legales
yo creo que siendo abogados nuestro
papel también es hacer un poco de
pedagogía explicar a nuestros clientes
que el juicio no no va a llevar todas
las respuestas el juicio es una etapa de
su reconstrucción pero el hecho de que
la fiscalía haya pedido cadena perpetua
para varios acusados es algo que es muy
poco común en francia en el cual estamos
muy poco acostumbrada a este tipo de
pena claro también le quiero preguntar
si usted en representación de estas
víctimas extranjeras han encontrado
dificultades para acceder a la justicia
más allá también de los comentaba de la
barrera del idioma por ejemplo para
entender lo que ocurría en este juicio
hablando digamos penalmente y en temas
de justicia que barreras han podido
encontrar o si no las han encontrado
bueno en forma general el sistema
francés prevé para víctimas un papel y
un acompañamiento de calidad o sea las
partes civiles tienen derecho a un
abogado de oficio
supuestamente pueden también tener
traducción los gastos de desplazamiento
cuando vienen a juicio todo esto está
cobrado eso es un sistema que es
bastante único en el mundo sin embargo
para los extranjeros de este juicio
había al empezar claramente una falta de
preparación del estado en la justicia
por ejemplo no habían previsto
intérpretes en cada idioma hablado por
las partes civiles antes de la audiencia
así que nos hemos organizado con varios
abogados que representaban también a
otros otras nacionalidades alemanes e
ingleses a los norteamericanos para
justamente hacer una forma de lubín y
para encontrar para que al final
nuestros clientes puedan acceder a la
justicia en la misma forma que víctimas
francesas y abogadas y antecedentes
sienta este mega juicio histórico que
hoy terminaría en la ciudad de parís en
cuanto a la justicia francesa
bueno es un juicio histórico por muchos
aspectos pero yo creo también es un poco
lo que le dice al empezar que el desafío
es que hoy no se juzga la historia hoy
se juzga a 20 individuos unos de los
cuales enfrentan en la cadena máxima la
pena máxima que es la pena de perpetua
yo creo que el más gran desafío para
estos jueces es lograr a pesar de todo
el hecho de que toda la comunidad
internacional está mirando les está
mirando nuestra justicia lograr aplicar
la ley y hacer y dar de una decisión que
conviene a las víctimas que conviene
también a la sociedad y que pueda
permitir también de que los acusados no
apelan todos porque en francés el
derecho de apelación entonces si la
decisión no es va lanzada si no es
equilibrada el riesgo mayor es que todos
los acusados apelan y que haya otro
juicio igual que sería también un
sufrimiento adicional para las víctimas
entonces hay estos intereses en los
cuales entre los cuales hay que hacer
como un triángulo para que para que al
final sea una buena justicia dada hoy y
que puedan nuestros clientes cerrar esta
página con tranquilidad
rápidamente abogada eso le quería
preguntar si realmente este juicio se
termina aquí está obviamente la la
posición la opción mejor dicho de apelar
no a este veredicto final realmente lo
ve posible que tan posible es que sea
que se presenten estas apelaciones
bueno la defensa y la fiscalía tienen
derecho a apelar de todo entonces es muy
probable que haya apelaciones excepto si
justamente la decisión satisface
básicamente a todos los intereses e
intereses en presencia es poco probable
que no haya ninguna apelación yo creo
que el desafío es que no haya
apelaciones por todos lados lo que
obligaría a francia a hacer otro juicio
inmenso abogada gracias por su tiempo
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 hablar un poco
entonces de lo que ha sido todo este
juicio histórico y cómo ha sido la
defensa sobre todo de las familiares y
las víctimas latinas involucradas en
estos atentados el 13 noviembre 2015 en
la capital francesa muchísimas gracias